good evening in southern Nevada grows
more problems on our roads the State
Department of Transportation has some
big plans for a popular recreational
destination and dog says they have come
up with a plan to improve safety along
State routes 159 and 160. better known
as the route to Red Rock Canyon in the
main road connecting Las Vegas to
Pahrump Ryan Matthey joins us live near
Charleston in the 215 in Summerlin Ryan
has some more
yeah Brian Denise it's 80 miles of
recommendations and throughout the two
highways endos says the the space right
behind me here that's where they've seen
the highest concentration of some of
those fatal collisions that's not to
Discount all the other fatal collisions
they've seen in some of the more rural
areas of this project now all of this is
to improve safety both for drivers and
bicyclists alike but not everybody is on
board
foreign
what's called critical Regional links
between Pahrump and Las Vegas the Nevada
Department of Transportation releasing
this study just this month that analyzed
five years of crashes along both
highways it revealed spots along both
routes that were most prone to deadly
collisions totaling 32 crashes and 35
fatalities the cars they like to skin
the white line and the bikers they like
to see what line Heather Fisher is
president of safe Red Rock a non-profit
that works to preserve and protect Red
Rock Canyon and its Recreation their
members some of the hundreds who gave
public input over the past year speed
control and widening from Pahrump to
Vegas and more roundabouts and bike
Lanes with a traffic buffer in Red Rock
Canyon we've been just trying really
hard to make sure that the visitors that
come to Red Rock can feel safe and be
safe our access is being curtailed but
concerns are with the 159 the Legacy
Trail will be built next to it a paved
bike path next to the bike lane on the
road ndot says it sees hundreds of
bikers there a week on top of thousands
of visitors to the canyon itself more
attraction to the area more traffic
control that frequent climber John
Hedges believes will inevitably lead to
more danger they're also really pushing
for more barriers with more toll booths
fees and reservations I don't think we
can say
everybody stop coming
make it more organized
Oregon I think
I think that will help with safety
now in the project it hasn't gotten the
green light yet ndot says they're still
looking for the funding source for it
all and according to n dot records it
could be upwards of 350 million dollars
reporting live from the 215 in
Charleston Ryan Matthey 8 News Now